[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الذكاء الاصطناعي يلعب دورا اساسيا في
تكنولوجيا درويش لمكافحه المسيارات فبينما
تستمر المسيارات بالتطور السريع نستخدم
نحن الذكاء الاصطناعيه في اجهزه الاستشعار
والاجراءات المضاده ودمج البيانات من
اجهزه الاستشعار المختلفه
[موسيقى]
اجراءات المضاده للمسيرات فعاله جدا نحن
لا نعتمد على اختراق بروتوكولات مسيرات او
اجراءات اخرى مشابهه لذلك بل نستخدم
التشويش الذكيه الذي يجعل من المستحيل على
السياره ان تفلت منه
[موسيقى]
على ماذا السنوات السبع الماضيه طور
فريقنا من المهندسين الحلول الثابته وتلك
التي يمكن للافراد والمركبات حملها كما
اننا نحدث برمجيات عملائنا كل ثلاثه اشهر
لضمان مواكبه انظمه لاحدث التهديدات كما
ان شركاتنا تعد شركه عالميه بخلاف العديد
من منافسين الذين يعملون محليا
[موسيقى]